si vous pensez que vous vivez le pire
confinement et que vous vous ennuyez
comme geagea penser aux chanteurs nice 4
qui en plus de rester enfermé chez lui
ses prix en pleine tête un huit sites de
la part de son ex aya nakamura
c'est le 20 mars dernier que
l'interprète de poux qui a décidé de
lancer un pic à tous ces ex sur snap
chatte alors qu elle posté une photo
avec son compagnon actuel la chanteuse
s'est permis une petite blague en
saluant tous ces anciens mec qui
visiblement n'avait pas la bonne taille
la bonne taille
big up à maaseik les nains de jardin et
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
nice cannes a pas beaucoup aimé la
blague
visiblement piqué au vif le rappeur a
répondu sur twitter y en a qui parlent
d'aix et même pas réciproque ex coup
d'un soir l'ex planque extraction de la
chambre juste après le sexe elle exagère
sauf que voilà y'a nakamura n'est pas du
genre à se laisser faire elle s'en est
d'abord pris à 10k en critiquant son
rôle de père toi t'as défi tu parles
comme ça mais bon comme tu t'en occupes
pas c'est normal
avant de s'en prendre une nouvelle fois
à son physique y en as tu parle vraiment
pas deux mais pour des soins qui
mettront moins ça non graves de respect
chacun qu'ils sont sains
il s'agissait de boire de la soupe est
un peu petit mais ce règlement de
comptes en public ne s'est pas arrêté là
faut dire que le confinement selon l'isq
a de nouveau répondu en insinuant cette
fois-ci caillard était un homme appelle
ton coeur tu es un gars bien aïe aïe aïe
souhaité avoir le dernier mot en
utilisant une photo du footballeur
djibril cissé sur laquelle il est
visiblement saoul et pour répondre à son
ex on est en 2010 leur coming out claqué
et devinez qui a répondu à ce tweet
n'ont pas dit ce cas mais djibril lui
même qui pour s'amuser s'est interrogé
mais qu'est ce que je fous là à moi bref
un échange aussi absurde qu'amusant qui
a permis aux internautes de passer le
temps devant cet épisode inédit de
scènes de ménages
ça ça ça a été énorme ça se fait
quelques estampes en chine moi je suis
totalement du côté d'ailleurs à cabourg
à nice qu'à saint pôtan mais bon va je
sais je voudrais lui aya nakamura
pour moi c'est une icône voilà un cc
vieux jeu l'idolâtrent donc je trouve
qu'elle fait ça avec humour un peu
caustique un peu grasse en mai c'est ce
qui me plaît chez elle rien dans la rue
but et là je trouve une détermination
sans faille
donc je lui trouve davantage dans ce
duel one jusqu'à nice kg tmd de skis
lamy franchement il a été très très
drôle aussi
moi les deux ils m'ont fait mourir de
rire et nous on fait tout le week-end
ils n'ont franchement ils nous ont
sortis aussi de la morosité ambiante les
deux avec les vannes qui sont envoyées
c'était énorme risque a été exceptionnel
benjamin castadi tu sais que si on parle
d'aller à la camorra unis ce cas où tu
crois que c'est laid c'est des modèles
chez ikea jeunes adultes vraiment très
drôle de nom je suis quand même l'étude
de près je trouve que c'est plutôt bon
enfant
après moi je suis pas fan de la camorra
vous le savez et les disques après voilà
il c'est une cible sans brouiller très
bien qu'ils le fassent mais ce type de
vols enfants il restait plutôt voilà
c'était pas c'est de bonne tenue comme
on dit